ينضم الينا من ديار بكر وليد العطار ديار
بكر معقل المكون الكردي في تركيا تحديدا
حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي وليد اطلعنا على
الاجواء الانتخابيه مع دخول تركيا ما يعرف
بالصمت الانتخابي عشيه الاقتراع
نعم جلال هذا الميدان الذي اقف فيه قبل
ساعات الصمت الانتخابي كان يعج
بالدعايه الانتخابيه لمختلف التحالفات
والاحزاب التركيه عندما وصلنا اليه بعد
السادسه مساء وجدناه خاويا تقريبا من كل
وسائل الدعايه صمت انتخابي كامل في
الدعايه المتحركه والدعايه الثابته هذا
هذه الان اجواء ترقب تعيش تحيئه تنتظرها
ديار بكر انتظارا لساعه بدء ساعات
الاقتراع في الثامنه صباحا هناك مليون
ومئه الف واربعمائه واربعين مليون و140
الفا تقريبا من الناخبين سيتوجهون الى
و675 صندوقا للانتخابات المكون الكردي هو
حجر زاويه وبيضه قبان كما يقال في هذه
الانتخابات كل التحالفات تسعى لاستقطابه
باصواته تحالف الجمهور الحاكم تحالف مع
حزب هدى المحافظ في مقابل تحالف غير معلن
كونه هو انشاه تحالف الشعب المعارض مع حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي الذي لن يخوض هذه
الانتخابات مباشره ولكن من خلال حزب
اليسار الاخضر كل هذه التداخلات السياسيه
في مقابل او يقابلها على الجانب الشعبي في
الشارع مع الناس الذين لقيناهم خلال
الايام الماضيه اشكالات البطاله اشكالات
قله فرص العمل التي شكى لنا منها كثير من
السكان هنا هذه الضغوط الاقتصاديه
والتداخلات السياسيه ستفرز
مؤكد ستفرد شيئا كثيرا في صناديق الاقتراع
يوم الاحد صباح الغد بعد عده ساعات من
الان